brought here on federal sentences on any
given day there could be up to 500
prisoners serving time at the Pacific
institution Correctional Facility in
Abbotsford
and it appears someone here may have
been the Mastermind behind a highly
unusual attempted drug smuggling it was
a little bit of confusion and shock to
be quite honest with you in my career
I've been around for almost 13 years and
I have never seen a live bird fly a
package into any institution or heard of
that it happened December 29th says John
Randall in the courtyard an outdoor area
within the confines of the Prison Walls
officers spotted a pigeon and a package
it was carrying before jumping into
action managed to capture it which I can
imagine was an interesting feat the way
it was described to me it was a small
fabric almost like a backpack
essentially tied to the bird and inside
that uh Park was was the the drugs the
bird was let go inside its package set
to be 30 grams of crystal meth the
situation is almost identical to a
cannabis seizure from a feathered
Smuggler in Peru back in May who was
caught carrying a package to the one
coyo Penitentiary
meanwhile closer to home in November the
mission institution was locked down
after it was believed a drone had
dropped a firearm onto prison ground
we've all heard the historic Tales of
carrier pigeons used most prominently in
the first world war to carry key
messages but most recently the bird has
been more commonly just referred to as
an urban past
it's almost like the inmates and the
criminals are going back in time and
using some older technology I guess is
the best way to describe it to to get
their Contraband in because we've done
such a good job or we're so diligent on
the Drone side of things now experts say
this could only be possible if a
prisoner had trained the bird prior to
the incident while the correctional
service of Canada won't discuss
specifics only that it is investigating
a matagahi global news